très bien
moi c'est pas possible il va tout gâcher
mais tu trouves pas qu'il exagère mais
c'est un réseau mais qu'est ce que dieu
veut que j'efface main chacun est
responsable de son stand mais va gâcher
toute notre fait il avait dit qu'il
apporterait des gâteaux à la crème des
pins des pistes des caramels tu devrais
lui parler bon tu as gagné je veux lui
dire deux mots
[Musique]
dits dans casimir à ce casting à
françois tu viens d'acheter quelque
chose à manger un
casimir de kits nocture mois mais glock
de personnes pourquoi mon secret jusque
12 ans si je l'avais vu qu'à bien sûr
quand je les ai vus puisqu'en six mois
qu'il est mis justement tu aurais pu
faire un meilleur choix
comment mais ce ne sont que des produits
de premier choix des spécialités de la
maison qu'ils regardent comme la
confiture de la confiture et bien mêler
aux escargots 1 il n'y a pas à ça le
grumeau burke est malade et c'est que
l'aso un choix tu as vu un jeu les faits
avec des fraises des bois que j'ai
cueilli moi même c'est pas super bien
peut-être mais dur je n'ai aucune envie
de manger pour ça me fait rien la maison
casimir en a pour tous les goûts qu'un
sang moi ce super génial gloubiboulga
nouvelle et mais dis-moi casimir le
gloubiboulga c'est bien de la banane
écrasée de la confiture de fraises de la
saucisse de toulouse tiède mais cru
d'accord avec de la moutarde et je vois
la râpée c'est ça exactement valeur ses
petits poings la bleue et blanche que je
vois qu est ce que ça aa gourma j'avais
bien vu que tu connais c'est le meilleur
et bien ça ce sont des morceaux de
roquefort que gmail et à la confiture
c'est succulent alala casimir tu
changeras jamais au met mais quel est ce
chef-d'oeuvre que tu prépares là sur ton
comptoir ah ça oui ça c'est une surprise
à une fantastique invention une
mirobolante découverte a
tué sur je crois que tu ferais peut-être
bien d'aller chercher des gâteaux pour
les enfants c'est bien qu'il déteste
tout ce que tu leur propose tu crois
j'en suis sûr en
c'est c'est vrai que vous n'aimez pas là
la glace aux anchois ni l'art ni la
confiture aux escargots way est par
contre vous aimez les choux à la crème
et la glace au chocolat bas bon écoute
françois je crois que tu as raison je
vais aller chercher d'autres choses pour
mon stand alors c'est très bien le seul
à toute allure casimir mans
voilà
et attention hein vous ne touchez pas à
ma super géniale invention fait pas que
tu crois que j'ai le temps de m'occuper
de ton invention avec toutes les
bouteilles que j'ai appliqué à vérifier
tout ne pas me tromper dans les poissons
qui ont des bulles et celles qui n'en
ont pas sans compter qu'il faut que je
vérifie
qu est ce qu est ce que tu veux toi eh
ben tu peux arrêter de parler
casimir est parti depuis longtemps
c'est toujours pareil avec vous ce que
jamais placé un mou j'ai ramé bonjour
monsieur distincts quelle surprise
comment allez-vous vous n'ignorez
sûrement pas que je suis chargé d'une
mission extrêmement important ben hop
bah non bien sûr c'est pas vous êtes
chargé de quoi non ma chère julie vous
êtes délicieuse de courant vous bien sûr
évidemment mais il expliqué quand même
julie
vous disiez rien je vous écoute vous
savez que la digue qui protège le port
est bien vieille et que l'on a demandé à
chaque habitant de chercher dans
l'endroit de lille où il vit la pire la
plus dure pour la protéger
eh bien je suis chargé d'aller trouver
chacun pour voir celui qui a trouvé la
pierre la plus dure pc formidable d'une
lourde responsabilité qu'ils avaient de
la chance c'est justement là la pierre
que je vais vous de vous apporter assez
de la craie
regardez c'est une pierre blanche et
très tendres ce qui permet d'écrire avec
mais ce n'est pas assez solide pour la
digue que je regrette voilà ce que j'ai
trouvé assez du grès est une pierre
admirable mais beaucoup trop friable
elle ne résistera pas aux vagues de la
mer je suis désolé c'est dommage et
quasiment
abba casimir est partie revient tout de
suite il est parti chercher des gâteaux
pour les enfants
qu'est-ce que ceux ci
mais ce matériau est tout à fait
admirable je ne savais pas qu on peut
citer des pierres aussi dur dans l'île
aux enfants des émirats peines à son
invention ce serait dont un mélange de
sa composition
bouleversant mélanie pas ma fantastique
invention rate casimir tu as raison tu
viens de faire quelque chose de génial
tous les habitants de l'île aux enfants
ne remercieront je tends commande va me
vingt mille 20 milles comme ça pour la
semaine prochaine encore bravo casimir
je suis très
fier de félicitations logique et merci
mais il ya quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas qu'est ce que c'est
pourquoi est ce que monsieur l'islande a
donné des coups de marteau avant de me
commander 20000 gâteau au chocolat
ton invention c'est du gâteau au
chocolat oui c'est un délicieux gâteau
au chocolat plein de crème fondante haut
que lui
[Musique]
bravo très bonnes réponses bon autre
chose maintenant continue quel est
l'animal qui court le plus vite
aleri les lions c'est pas le lion
à l'autruche va très très vite mais
c'est pas l'autruche le liège relief ça
va très très vite aussi c'est un livre
c'est pas le cheval 2010 et le guépard
et à quelle vitesse courte il se lance
[Applaudissements]
50 kilomètres à l'heure non plus vite
intenable presque
110 kilomètres à l'heure le guépard et
l'animal qui court le plus vite il court
à 110km à leurs familles
alors une autre question maintenant un
coup rhinocéros est accro rhinocéros à
votre avis quelle vitesse il peut courir
se fit
gilchrist en poche
il faut me
répondit
45 kilomètres à l'heure et oui un gros
rhinocéros sac ou à 45 kilomètres à
l'heure c'est formidable nous
tiens vous êtes là cela dit je vous
n'auriez pas vu casimir par hasard non
est ennuyeux on a été obligé de
commencer à jouer sans lui et vous savez
quand il est pas là bas c'est nettement
moins amusant on écoute et on continue
quand même une autre question
quel est l'animal qui saute le plus aux
rails et ziadi gilles le puma c'est ça
et à quelle hauteur subtil
dominique
l1 être non plus aux quatre médecins peu
trop ils sont à trois mètres de haut et
oui le puma et l'animal qui sont le plus
haut il fait des bonds de plus de trois
mètres de haut extraordinaire et chez
les oiseaux il ya deux champions de
vitesse et des échos qui sont ils
non c'est pas l'autruche et les oiseaux
brownienne à l'hirondelle ça coûte ça
vole très vite mais c'est à l'hirondelle
non je vous le dit m c'est l'aigle
impérial
et le faucon pèlerin
voilà et quelle est leur vitesse
sa fille ça va très très vite alors là
c'est vraiment un
[Applaudissements]
combien valérie
160 kilomètres à l'heure est-ce que vous
rendez compte que l'aigle impérial et le
faucon pèlerin vol à 160 kilomètres à
l'heure mais casimir toujours par là
mais ça commence à m'inquiéter vous
savez les enfants vous allez jouer mais
moi je voir ce qui se passe d'accord on
recommence à plus tard à tout à l'heure
tu n'aurais pas vu kazimi aujourd'hui ah
non c'est vrai je n'avais pas fait
attention enfin il devrait être là il
savait bien qu'on faisait un jeu mais
oui ce n'est pas du tout normal il a dû
se passer quelque chose je sais
l'écoutent je ne voudrais pas avoir
l'air de faire des raconta mais il
aurait dit aux facteurs qu'il était très
malheureux parce que nous étions très
aimable avec monsieur du snop sous
prétexte que c'est un homme de qualité
mais en fait c'est ridicule de ce bien
dessus pas vrai on est on est poli avec
monsieur 10 nab c'est vrai mais notre
préféré c'est notre casino c'est évident
c'est évident pour tout le monde mais
sans doute pas pour lui mais si
succeptibles héros mal compris et il a
l'air de penser qu'on ne les aime plus
pourvu qu'il disparaisse pas encore
pendant plusieurs jours mes chers amis
au patron jean mois
enfin casimir c'est toi
on passe alors pour une surprise les dom
et de bravos à casimir ma très chère
julie je vous serais très reconnaissant
de bien vouloir m'appeler monsieur
casimir chez nous les gens de qualité
c'est une habitude à laquelle nous
restons très attachés
ça alors pour une surprise des dons les
bravos casimir tu nous as fait une bonne
farcissez c'est vrai tu nous as bien lu
demi chers amis il s'agit nullement
d'une farce
le casimir grotesque et lourdaud que
vous avez connue n'existe plus vous avez
devant vous un nouveau casimir qui
depuis aujourd'hui suit des cours de
maintien chez monsieur jacques aujourd
hui
et dillon casimir walt tue vraiment au
sérieux ouais et alors enfin je veux
dire à tout à fait rire quel dommage
qu'il se soit repris avec asie mais j'en
ai tôt ouais et alors ne m'avait fait
autant de plaisir fou de vouloir tout
changer nous t'aimons tels que tu es
avec tes petites chansons tes petits pas
de danse la gaieté on est même des
collèges
mais vous préférez les gens de qualité
mais pas du tout casimir non nous aimons
les gens tels qu'ils sont et nous aimons
bien monsieur du stop c'est vrai mais
notre préféré notre favori c'est toi
c'est notre casino et du le sait bien
mais attention hein hein casimir
authentique son chapeau son noeud
papillon 100 fleuret et sans canne et
son coup de maître caché naître au zoo
regardez
ce qu'ils nomment qu'est ce que c'est
dites nous imiter casimir ouais alors
impôts quelle raison parce que j'ai
compris que tout votre affection aller à
casimir parce qu'il est plus gai que moi
plus à plus amusant mais maintenant je
saurai troll regardez-moi
ça c'est les passagers dont le chauffeur
et puis toi aussi qu'à finir manquer ce
qui vous prend tous les deux voulaient
tous les dires va redevenir comme avant
on avait compris nos vaisseaux vapeur au
métier c'est la première fois que je me
mets en colère après la première fois
[Musique]